when you're fighting cancer attending
college is a difficult thing to wrap
your head around and that's where
Southern Nevada's non-profit Critical
Care Comics is trying to help right now
you can apply for the critical care
comic Survivor scholarship it's open to
high school seniors who have battled or
are currently battling cancer typically
the non-profit volunteers and
superheroes visit kids in the hospitals
passing out comic books bringing a smile
to their faces and now they want to help
cover college tuition
Brookshire Tango always had it in his
head that he wanted to have three major
Awards so once we were able to get we
got a sizable donation from Scott the
woz who was a YouTuber and once we were
able to get that very extremely generous
donation automatically he said I am
taking 50 000 and I am putting it aside
for the scholarship
so three applicants will be awarded 30
grand 15 000 or 5 000 based on their
essays they must have at least a 3.0 GPA
the winners will be announced in early
May and we will of course follow